maurice
yes indeed we're with the big mk the big
kahuna
for the grand chess tour mike thanks for
joining us
you must be pleased with seeing more
chess happening over the board
it's been a tremendous success for the
tour so far with these three events
absolutely maurice it's a very good
event
for us a lot of viewership
especially with gary's participation
although
he is not in good form but anyway
the viewers uh watching the games and
they understand that this is not online
games it's in person
and players also hungry to play over the
board
we can feel it tingling with excitement
but we know you have even
more exciting news about next year's
tour
yes actually we already set up
schedule for season 2022
and i'm happy to announce that we will
have
a new spot a new leg
in warsaw poland another
european capital joining the tour
incredible so tell us all the events
that will happen will be all five events
that happen this year
and next year in poland as well in
warsaw well actually
uh next year it will be very heavy
schedule
very heavy calendar for because there
will be
three grand prix feeder events uh
qualifiers for the candidates tourism
then candidate story then world team
championships
then world olympiad so therefore
we really need to squeeze everything
in in order not to have a conflict so
we're working
with feeding collaboration in order to
make
balance calendar and actually we
succeeded
we will have uh like this here
uh five events in the regular season
starting in bucharest with classical
events going to paris
then going to zagreb and then new
spot as i mentioned it would be warsaw
warsaw will substitute
san luis rabbit and bleeds just for one
year
because of this heavy calendar but
uh sinful cup as a classical event
remains the same as round rex's birthday
as a matter of fact
exact same feel the namesake of that
event we'll close it out
i will say this is a great schedule i'm
sure the polish fans
are jumping up and down young christoph
duda probably knows he's already a wild
card
in that event you're expanding you said
only
you only stayed at five because of the
busy schedule
for for next year fee day's busy
schedule but that
is less busy in the following year are
you planning to expand the grand chess
tour
in 2023 well first of all we will in
2023 we will
reinstate saint louis rapid and bleeds
but we have some other spots on the
pipeline so it's
very possible that we will bring another
capital in europe on our tour
not to mention that we're still
contemplating to have a finals
so but it must be seen and it will be
announced after single cup
i guess i better start packing my bags
now incredible
tour well thank you so much for that
announcement again
i'm sure the polish fans are thrilled
congratulations on a successful
tour so far and we'll see you in saint
louis for the st louis rapido blitz
absolutely
looking forward to that and to conclude
i want to appreciate
all sponsors that support grandchild's
tour obviously this includes chess club
superbad vivendi and
looking forward for the next flick
absolutely thank you so much for joining
us michael
guys back to you in the studio thank you
maurice and thank you
michael for those announcements and
hello warsaw this is marvelous